là ce sont des macarons à la framboise
j'en ai fait au moins je pense six ans
depuis le depuis le premier confinement
c'est son engagement solidaire dans le
contexte actuel florence le tueur que
réalise des pâtisseries pour les
personnes mobilisées face à la crise
sanitaire
c'est quelques c'est quelque chose qui
est ancré en moi c'est le plaisir de
faire plaisir le plaisir d'apporter du
réconfort et et c'est quelque chose qui
me porte et qui nous portent tout dans
cette chaîne solidaire en tous les cas
puisqu'on le fait depuis longtemps
maintenant faim depuis plus d'un an avec
elle une vingtaine de personnes
pâtissent au sein de la team banos fit
une équipe basée entre maisons laffitte
et le mesnil le roi engagés dans la
chaîne solidaire vos gâteaux
ce jour là les gâteaux vaut prendre la
direction de plusieurs casernes de
pompiers montesson mesnil le roi et où y
la récolte des pâtisseries se fait place
de l'église le kouglof magnifique à
muffins ce banane chocolat qui partent
poire chocolat trop sympa merci beaucoup
direction ensuite la caserne de houille
sartrouville pour florence le turc
les soldats du feu ont l'embarras du
choix parmi ces gourmandises sa réel
plaisir de recevoir autant de jolies
choses c'est à dire des petites choses
mais finalement ce n'est pas forcément
le cas ce qu'il y en a tellement que ça
devient des grosses aux nous ça nous
apporte quand même tous d'amour dans
tout ça pour la timba nofit la
mobilisation se poursuit
la crise sanitaire le début de cette
histoire saupoudrait de bonne humeur et
nappez d'humanité